ok let's get into audience questions for
the week second to last set of audience
questions for 2018 many more coming in
2019 no doubt first question today hey
David okay I get it you're against the
Mexican wall how should we deal with
undocumented immigration so first of all
let before we even get into that I'm
against the wall because I feel as
though what it costs relative to the
benefit in terms of solving the problem
it will supposedly solve and the way in
which it's being used as a political
football to foment ignorant political
activism is overall destructive I
haven't argued that a wall would be
against the law
I haven't argued that there would be
anything objectively wrong with the wall
morally it's a question of what is the
problem that we claim exists and with
the solution that Trump is proposing of
a wall solve it and at what cost okay so
that now we can actually dig into the
question the most important thing to
consider do you want something that
works to solve the problem you've
identified or do you want to do
something that makes you feel as though
you're the alpha male and you're
punishing people for things that they
are doing wrong in your eyes let's put
it this way if we want to stop people
from coming to the United States
illegally and from staying here beyond
how long they were legally authorized to
come to the US and to stop consuming law
enforcement resources of time and money
all of that stuff the wall is not the
best way to do it in terms of its
effectiveness in and in terms of its
cost so to be very very clear consider
that it's not obvious that the United
States even wants this to actually
happen because what would happen if we
actually solved the undocumented
immigration that exists coming to the
United States well if we did that border
patrol is almost out of business you'd
still need some force but it would be
decimated in terms of what you would
need ice would be out of jobs
tons of detentions
there's private and public would close
seizures of drugs valuable to law
enforcement would stop now this is not a
defense of undocumented immigration what
I'm pointing out is that similar to
speeding tickets we are organizing to
stop a behavior on which we actually
depend and think about speeding tickets
for a second the police don't want you
to speed or Society doesn't want you to
speed so we have fines for speeding and
police stop you if you speed and say you
are now getting a ticket if you want to
avoid tickets then simply stop speeding
if everybody stopped speeding the police
departments would lose a ton of money in
that same way if we were actually
successful at stopping undocumented
immigration without passing judgment
without making an analysis beyond this
fact if we actually stopped undocumented
immigration to the United States then we
would be putting out of jobs a ton of
people and we would be significantly
limiting the funds to many of the
departments that are involved in
fighting that I merely point that out so
that we all can have a more realistic
conversation where we can actually
question do politicians actually even
really want to stop undocumented
immigration to the United States let's
pretend that we do want to fix this
issue what would be more sensible than a
wall number one drones and cameras and
the use of technology are in many ways
better than fences because you can
identify from a much greater distance
what it is that is going on and then you
can target law enforcement immigration
authorities to areas where people are
actually actively trying to cross over
I'm not saying you you get rid of all
border fencing that is there but I'm
saying if we want to think about what
else might we do other than building
this outrageously expensive wall which
still wouldn't actually be a solution to
the problem why else wouldn't it be a
solution to the problem well lots of
people are coming to the United States
legally either as tourists or
overstaying other types of visas if you
really want to deal with the number of
people that are in the United States
illegally undocumented beyond the amount
of time that they were supposed to be
here then you would realize that the
number of physical border crossings is
actually not the majority of the people
that are here and you
deploy resources elsewhere would it be
cheap absolutely not would it be
efficient I don't know those people are
spread out across the United States but
if you are serious about fixing the
problem you identify that would be a
place to focus more energy very
importantly sue and find companies that
hire undocumented immigrants this
includes Donald Trump's companies Donald
Trump's personal housekeeper we found
out at his New Jersey Golf Club was an
undocumented immigrant
in the United States if they cannot get
jobs in the United States remember
they're coming here to work they're not
lazy many are going to stop coming here
and as I've said before companies love
this companies want to have people here
that they can hire particularly people
who will number one accept low salaries
because there are they going to complain
their status here is in question and who
are vulnerable knowing that they are
here illegally so they are unlikely to
complain about working conditions or
anything else so we need to actually
start punishing the companies we have a
legal infrastructure to do that members
of Congress benefit from undocumented
immigration the social welfare system
benefits from undocumented immigration
because contrary to what you often hear
you have people paying into the system
who are here illegally who are never
going to get benefits out because they
are here illegally it's free money for
the welfare social welfare system and
many programs not all obviously if
you're not paying into that you're
you're not part of what I'm saying but
many undocumented immigrants are lastly
spend money that you would spend on a
wall working with the countries people
are coming from to better circumstances
so that the incentive to come to the
u.s. is diminished I've said this before
many people come to the US because they
perceive that things are going to be
better for them here than in their home
country accounting for the fact that
many are abandoning their families for
long periods of time if not indefinitely
that they risk being arrested and then
deported and being in a worse off
situation so
if we actually work with some of these
countries not in this I'm gonna make you
pay for a wall which then Mexico says
we're not paying for it and that
relationship erodes work with them if
we're going to spend the money anyway we
would be far better off improving
economic conditions in source countries
for undocumented immigration and it
would have the stimulative effect of
making it so that more people have money
to come to the United States as tourists
everybody would win in that in that case
many less expensive and more effective
options than building the wall we should
also have a better functioning guest
worker program that will curb a lot of
undocumented immigration and remember
illegal immigration is on a downward
trend outflow to Mexico exceeds inflow
from Mexico of undocumented immigrants
at this time so if we are really going
to have a conversation about this it's
not just how effective would the wall be
it's are we actually serious about
solving the problem or is it a political
football because think about all of the
constituencies that benefit from
undocumented immigration and beyond that
what is the nature of the problem
because it's not actually people
physically crossing the border at least
not a plurality of those individuals
send me your thoughts